нідерланди porsche окраїна євросоюзу
століття і підкоряється так званий парад ви
великих компаній повіт 2017 раку
результати голосування може без
посередників пливуть і на парламентській
вибір у Франції на вас не
town матчі його син і у паші за втомиться
десятиліття праві популісти з партії
свобода герта вілдерса
може вранці від та найбільшу fractions
нижній палаті парламенту
а пом'яли існує наш прем'єр-міністр
народ назвав ти вибору чорт фіналом
європейський вибір
ти фіналом стануть вибори у Франції
фіналом голосування в імідж і не
ще у нас вілдерс модему хороший
результат
ті телком може планетою і на Францію і
починати інструментів і скликав кіль
коротких тому професор Янсен напасів
польщу і поки що їжі на нідерландах
каналу про історію України експерт з
українського харчування поважаючи для розрахунку
влада пройде і популісти нідерланди
залиш точно видно вулиця вид ратифікації у
води прошу частиною mesh е100 україну you
спробуєш партія герта вілдерса складу
я серйозну конкуренцію палець або
прем'єра марка рютте
на вулицях амстердама мало хто
погладжуєте довірить і про у тата листам
управління україною не безневинно привіт
сім'ї дорівнює будуть другом на виборах я
голосуватиму за нього купа провини дивний
просто я не люблю іслам
там буду за ним у будинках тис і виходу
з'їсться була добра щоб ми самі могли
би малювати як-28 політичних партій
виручку частиною виборів на натиснувши зони
спокою не результати виборів на до
розправи polystyl може під воріт і
російські хакери c у чоловіка
електронний пі дракон куті сиф пояс не
айти спеціаліст Олександр
сніда love в нідерландах навіть багата
пахло даються насправді на автоматизацію
на комп'ютерні системи тут бата берша а
багата бірж автомата зол на різьблених
аспекті в тому числі вибір чого процесу
не нижче в Україні і це було повно світу
форма
ще автомата зайти означає в розгризти
ще в заповідь ти маніпуляціям
центрального велика комісія прайма ти
ми протоколи тільки у спробу виглядали
упершись касу на всю передачу
електронних даних про ті популісти на
зустрічають знайди її так і стати
найсильніша партія на тих виборах ви
не заявляти всю ману луму соціологи вже
не розпорошувалися а і на жаль тортури brexit і
допомагати трампу а також raw оренду
машину асоціації з Україною
у тих же нідерландах теж interlock диво
результаті в парламентських виборах у
нідерландах зберігаєте
до завершення педро хонг на жаль лосів